okay don't tell my Dad I'm making this  video Sasha would be so pissed  mocktails is [ __ ] exploding I've been  talking to my friends about this for two  three years as a trend I want to talk  more about business opportunities on  this platform actually leave a comment  if you think me talking about white  space narrow business opportunities is a  good use of this Instagram and something  you'd be all excited about if you're an  entrepreneur and you want to get into a  space mocktails is massive and overall  this is going to become a thing right  like people are going to continue to eat  cleaner big shout out Mona healthier all  that stuff it's coming it's real it is  absolutely here and look at this alcohol  with no alcohol in it fake alcohol mock  Tails big space if you want to open up a  mocktail bar if you want to start a  mocktail brand if you want to start a  garnish or supportive product for  mocktails maybe a glassware brand